it's been suppressed recently last week
you you came out you said you were you
were critical of Senate live were used
to work sure for booking Trump to host
the show while he was campaigning for
president you thought that that was a
mistake in in retrospect for me and it's
mostly about just my personal experience
with it and how I feel about it I think
as time goes on and and our current
president kind of reveals his character
or lack thereof I I personally have a
hard time of having been involved in an
endorsement of that you know um it's not
it's not necessarily a critique of the
show but but uh boy it's it's it's it's
really hard to have played a part in in
sort of encouraging or not even
encouraging but just offering a platform
and promoting for someone who who I find
I'm constantly disappointed in you know
I had one I worked at starting out live
a long long time ago and in those days
but I've heard it's still the same the
writers would sometimes go out with the
host of the show and the producer to
have dinner mm-hmm and I'm told that you
writers and performers would go that you
amantha on that dinner you went to
dinner with Trump the week that he did
Senate live that's right yeah uh there's
a there's a host dinner and and some of
the cast and writers are invited and and
it was it was tense and but but I will
say specifically to Lawrence credit if
he has someone hosting you treat their
guests in our house that's that's that's
Lawrence attitude and I think exactly I
think that's the right out of there yeah
and I admire him for that but it was a
tricky one and and and again upon
reflection and just my personal
experience with it he said something of
that host dinner that just shy I found
at the time shocking and now more so
where they were talking about yeah
you're running for president and what a
what a big thing to take on he's like
you know listen if I don't win this
thing I'm gonna be fine
we just bought this huge property in
Scotland if I have to be present I'm
never gonna see that thing
I know what a weird I know yeah the
priorities were wrong so you're saying
that right now as president and leader
of the free world he's constantly
thinking about I've got to get to my
effing place in Scotland and by the way
like when well hasn't he been golfing
anyway well that's passed and you know I
don't you know who knows do you I don't
think Star Night Live's suede the
election necessarily I don't either wait
a minute yes it did
you